[Music]
I often espouse a general philosophy in
my life of pursuing a discipline of one
sort or another but it's not it's not to
ever approach any level of perfection
you start you go in knowing that as
human beings we never can achieve
perfection and so I feel like mastery of
any skill or art form really more
involves becoming much better at
covering your mistakes but no matter how
much of a virtuoso a person becomes I
feel like if they're still in the
mentality of a student or pursuing their
discipline then they'll never finish you
know ripping out a Beethoven symphony or
playing a game of basketball and say
there I've done it that was the perfect
rendition instead what's what keeps us
living and what keeps me vitally engaged
is a constant pursuit of betterment so I
I gave up on perfect a long time ago and
now you know I'm just chasing halfway
decent part of this philosophy I'm
talking about came to me naturally I
grew up in a family out in the country
in Illinois both my mom and dad grew up
on farms I grew up working on my mom's
family's farms and so we were very
frugal it was very little House on the
Prairie in the 70s and 80s which means
we had a television but we were still
raising as much garden as we could and
everything you know we got this free
farmhouse in exchange my dad had to
build some cabinets for this farmer and
we hired a guy to roll this house six
miles and then we spent our lives there
improving it we'd paint in every couple
years we built a little barn and so I
don't know just by naturally learning to
enrich in my own life through my
activities yeah I complained about it a
lot you know I wasn't a 12 year old
saying hey Dad is there something I can
dig up for you this weekend you know I
was griping like any kid I wanted to
stay in and watch cartoons and so we
would work out a deal and the thing that
I see as a major difference between my
childhood and a lot of society today is
that we've become so good at comforting
ourselves consumer luxury has become
sort of a given you know in most walks
of life in this country you can choose
to live a life of ease where you never
have to really try very hard you can you
can cruise through school as long as you
get passing grades you can get some job
with which you can cover your your
living expenses and that allows you to
just watch TV play video games to to
amuse yourself to engage in leisure all
of the time you're not earning your
living and to a certain frame of mind
that might sound attractive but I've
kind of tried it at times a lot of
marijuana was also involved in my
particular formula and I quickly learned
that it's depressing that I don't know
for me I quickly thought what are you
doing with your life are you just gonna
watch cool movies and then die like it's
again to the you know to a certain part
of the of the it'd I think that sounds
like a great idea
let's just hang out and watch The Big
Lebowski over and over but for me
thankfully because of my chemistry I
came to understand that even if I wasn't
succeeding you know even if I was making
woodworking projects in an alley in Los
Angeles 25 years ago I was improving and
they were crappy and I
and I would make mistakes but I pretty
soon came to learn that those mistakes
were some of the most valuable time I
ever spent because if you want to become
great at something whether you want to
make a living at it or there there are
other ways to make a happy living than
earning money there are a lot of people
who don't like their jobs but who go
home and knit or they go home and take
care of kids or they cook or they do any
number of things with their hands they
engage that this magic toolset called
the human body and there's so much that
it can that it can achieve that it's
satisfying that may never pay you a
dollar but it makes your life incredibly
happy and that's the lesson I would try
to pass along Neil Gaiman says something
really profound about about mistakes you
know that it's it's a New Year's
benediction that he gave and to
paraphrase he says I hope that in the
coming year you have blessings and
health and and all that but I really
hope that you make mistakes because if
you make mistakes it means you're out
there trying it means you're taking a
swing at achieving something and if
you're not making mistakes it means
you've given up and you'll you're
becoming one of those fat baby people
floating around on the chairs in the
movie wall-e eating everything is some
kind of weird milkshake I don't know for
me I I love making things out of wood
I'm making nine ukuleles right now in my
shop in Los Angeles and they're going to
be just fine they're gonna sound like
ukuleles but I don't know if I'll ever
make one that that a great musician
would pick up and say wow how did you
make it sound so amazing I know that and
that's okay because there's a lot of
other people who can pick up my ukuleles
and I'll just keep him out of Clapton's
hands if he comes around I'll be like
yeah I don't know where I think we got
these at a garage sale
but they're beautiful and and they're
full of mistakes I could show you ten
mistakes and ever
instrument and I'm not even done yet but
it doesn't matter when it all goes
together people and people look at it
they see your creation they're not gonna
say well you got three things wrong
they're gonna say holy cow this sounds
like a ukulele I can play several Mills
Brothers songs on this thing and and so
I don't know at the end of all that for
me as a human animal I've stayed out of
the pub I haven't hurt anybody
I haven't purchased anything that a
corporation made and perhaps that
corporation is not being as mindful of
our natural resources as we would prefer
so I've not added to any landfills but
you know purchasing a crappy version of
the thing I made that will break and get
thrown away and so it's a general
pursuit of trying to add things to the
world trying to help rather than hurt
[Music]